[Musique]
voici enfin le nouveau visage aux
commandes de la ville bernard de bain
tout juste promu conseiller municipal en
lieu et place de philippe lavaud prend
donc la direction de saint cyr l'école
élu au premier tour de scrutin avec 17
voix à la majorité absolue
une tâche qui s'annonce ardue face à une
opposition revendicative
alors que la majorité apparaît plus que
jamais divisée moi je suis un homme
d'écouté de dialogue donc de toute façon
je pense que si on veut arriver à à
gérer cette ville on peut pas le faire
avec une opposition systématique est le
seul moyen de de pouvoir la gérer avec
l'opposition c'est de l'associer à nos
travaux la première action du nouveau
maire sera sans doute de rallier les
cinq dissidents de la liste saint cyr à
venir à sa cause
cinq conseillers dont gaétan desjardins
ancienne première adjointe exclu par le
groupe majoritaire pour avoir contesté
les méthodes de philippe lavaud moi
effectivement je n'étais pas toujours
d'accord avec monsieur lavaud
j'étais d'accord sur les projets puisque
c'étaient nos projets lorsque nous avons
été élus et je n'étais pas d'accord sur
les méthodes
moi j'aime la rigueur la transparence la
concertation la discussion
la dictature je n'aime pas beaucoup
candidate de l'opposition brigitte
berthomieu réclamé quant à elle la
démission générale du conseil afin de
provoquer de nouvelles élections auprès
des saint-cyriens il nous dit j'assume
j'assume tout le passé les mandats
l'équipe l'équipe passé avait un mandat
des saint-cyriens bon je n'ai pas
l'impression quand même que le mandat
qui avait été donnée par les saint
cyriens l'équipe municipale était d
illégalité les crises les déchirements
nous donne quelques explications sur la
situation financière de la ville
le chantier s'annonce donc laborieux
entre l'hypothétique annulation de la
vente de la gendarmerie
tout le dossier épineux de la piscine à
zéro euro quoi qu'il en soit bernard de
bain semble être l'homme du dialogue
retrouvé plusieurs conseillers
d'opposition déclarant hier à
l'auditoire ne plus être habitué depuis
longtemps à temps de concertation
réveil difficile ce matin pour les 3000
salariés du technocentre renault à
guyancourt ils ont passé la nuit dans
les salles de réunions dans les bureaux
dans les amphithéâtres bloqués par la
neige
on a essayé de proposer des repas alors
c'était pas toujours le repas habituel
mais des repas chauds on a été faire les
stocks les yaourts les fruits qu'on
pouvait trouver un peu partout de mettre
le chauffage des maîtres l'électricité
parce que normalement à 3 heures du
matin au technocentre n'y a pas
d'électricité ou pas beaucoup et pour
assurer l'ambiance la direction a même
proposé un concert au coeur de
l'entreprise des professeurs de musique
ont proposé leurs services ils ont joué
jusqu'à 1h30 du matin là au coeur du
technocentre dans la rue il y avait à
peu près 1000 personnes autour d'eux et
ils ont joué comme ça dans une ambiance
complètement à part complètement
surréaliste et les gens ils étaient
autour et et après ils ont essayé
d'aller se coucher enfin de se coucher
façon de parisot essayer d'aller d'aller
s'endormir et ce matin il se réveille
là ils sont un peu longs nez à tous un
peu fatigués on a tous plus ou moins
bien dormi c'était un peu trop court un
peu trop long
la nuit a été forcément difficile on n'a
pas super bien dormi mais c'est quelque
chose qu'il fallait vivre chance c'était
sympa plutôt de vie dans sa voiture
coincée
pire une bonne ambiance pour repartir ce
matin la solidarité a battu son plein un
service de covoiturage s'est mis en
place
chacun venant proposer son aide à ses
collègues on a beaucoup de propositions
de personnes qui proposent donc de
transporter et de ramener les gens chez
eux et
donc tout le monde est très volontaire
et on a aussi donc des personnes qui
recherchent et qui viennent qui prennent
les petits post it qui repartent et qui
auront une solution pour ne pas dormir
ce soir encore au technocentre une nuit
finalement agréable au technocentre pour
les salariés qui ce jeudi soir ont tous
quitté le site
mais beaucoup s'interrogeaient encore
sur le manque de communication de la
préfecture sur la conduite à suivre et
sur l'état des routes
[Musique]